hello and welcome to this video with the
right number let me check yes playing in
psych very high rating no bullet rating
very new account yeah so it seems like
he's going for me sort of okay that's
different it's different I wanted to say
sort of a hedgehog
you hear the normal way to players to
play with f1 and f5 later
if one active Blackwell probably
captured and now you're going for a pawn
to e5 naturally form trying to initiate
some play on the kingside where you have
more space Mikey five yeah that looks
like a decent way of playing for black
trying to get the knight to deform not
so when it's it's not super necessary
okay
to G from probably to d4 so what is
black up to moving the F pawn maybe I
can try it take take this this annoyed
it's not a bad square for the yeah we're
thinking g4 could be good yeah maybe I'm
wrong so deform
not not very certain about it
now just angling for night for rook h3c
to prove to provoke some witnesses okay
so
and night Knight to e4 would be would be
still quite nice
don't don't really have a good square
for the Queen down
trying to make use of the king
okay I'm taking with the ponds that no
that may be making Mamie I was just
trying to say is it better than it looks
and my conclusion was it is not better
than it looks
it looks bad and it's bad for him okay
so let's go here I've got some pressure
on f7 which is not not really important
problem he's got some pressure on d3
yeah I was hmm well I saw this idea but
I didn't think it is really helping him
but especially after king f2 it does
help him it was that wasn't great
pretty awful
I don't know what went wrong actually I
felt my position was okay for most of it
okay five its of course it's a
structural weakness but I should be able
to limit this this problem
really odd
I don't know what went wrong to be
honest here repeat many won't make a
draw here of course but III Atlas's
closer to the Paso
it's unfortunately lost yeah yeah where
did I waited disco wrong I mean here I
don't think I'm in any particular
trouble also may be timing it's possible
maybe I'm not timing this correctly and
I mean here I can play many moves before
I push it five and maybe I should wait
actually because yeah
maybe I should wait with this when I'm
clearly not in trouble or anything but
yeah this was probably not the best way
of playing yeah he D four is the
simplest way of doing things maybe I
should just play that based on the fact
that the D three point is not good yeah
and she D four also using the offside
piece
yeah yeah I thought I should be fine but
that whole plenty of it the king was
probably completely wrong
I feel if I'm playing it right here so
should be okay which is supported by the
engine like of course not better I
shouldn't be terrible out here a way I
play it
you just gets the bishop over to c7 and
I have no clear recipe against it I only
spotted it too late and now after they
say I have no counterclaim no count play
it off I would the key position is
probably here when you played this when
I should play d4 keeping this outside of
the plane yeah that's a lot better
playing in the center it's a lot better
and probably I should not play e5 so
early and it's too early okay thanks a
lot for watching